I'm trying to add Camila to the chat
says she's unable to join her larious
live chats a steamy new music video guys
what did we do to deserve Shawn Mendes
and Camila Kibeho I've never worked as
the extra songwriter who I clicked with
as well as her Camila and Shawn released
the video for seniorita and there's so
many steamy moments that were breaking
them all down you're welcome first Shawn
on a motorcycle need i say more then
when they do this back and forth looking
at each other thing in the diner
yep that's two moments before the
singing even starts guys has Camila ever
looked this good more back and forth
only this time Shawn is playing the
guitar so there's that and then the
dancing begins
this moment Shawn taking off his shirt
and yeah we're just gonna let the hotel
scene play out for a sec
[Music]
hard to believe it gets even hotter than
that but it does
[Music]
the
I'm gonna need a minute you guys are
just friends right yeah we're just
friends he's like one of my best friends
he's amazing yeah I did ask them both if
they were just friends a few years ago
we are just friends reticent we're not
dating
I also like to think that I've been
manifesting this follow up since been
competing [ __ ] you guys write more songs
together
she's amazing like super talented a
songwriter while their chemistry was off
the charts they're 2015 collab I know
what you did last summer climbed the
charts
with this song it was so spontaneous
like we kind of just wrote it for the
sake of writing it not even I didn't
even think that it would be heard
anywhere or like be released anywhere so
when his label picked it as a single I
was kind of like okay cool but I think
like I'm just you know it's really it's
a really cool thing that happened but I
don't think you can plan those things I
don't aside from the music video the
other best part of last night was Shaun
and Camilla failing so hard I Instagram
live in the best way ever I sent it to
her phone so I'm live on Instagram
another fifty six thousand people
watching guys this is bad we're having
seriously I I don't understand how we
don't know how to do this definitely
both did you not get the notification
saying that I invited you right now this
is gonna work right now why are you
doing it from your Instagram 4,600
requests to be in my video so you're in
one of their in one of those live with
someone else
[Music]
we're really really genuinely struggling
right now trying to figure out how to do
this I mean the best right no me neither
such good secret-keeping skills
I want to know what part of the video
you love the most though so let me know
and for all the latest on Sean and
Camila keep it locked to all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]